police can't down the alleged killer
chef Shekar in Strasbourg snide of
neighbourhood the 29 year old grew up
here security forces finally caught up
with him on Thursday evening a full two
days after the attack on the city's
popular Christmas market this individual
matched the description of the person
wanted since Tuesday evening at the
moment they tried to arrest him he
turned around and opened fire they then
responded and managed to shoot him down
chef Shekar was already known to police
for his long criminal record and radical
Islamist beliefs before he
indiscriminately opened fire near the
Christmas market store but he managed to
escape security has been heavy in
Strasbourg since then now people say
they are relieved it's finally safe to
go out the christmas market is reopening
on friday
france remains on high alert in the wake
of the large number of terrorist attacks
which have shocked the country in recent
years
[Music]
Tuesday's attack has left Strasbourg in
mourning but determined not to given
despite the latest terrorist outrage and
our correspondent Helena Humphrey is in
Strasbourg and Helena we we understand
that you actually witnessed the police
operation last night walk us through
what happened that's right Sarah shortly
after 9:00 p.m. here in France I was
walking with my colleague when we saw
three police vans make their way down
the road just behind me at high speed
despite this being a pedestrian area
blue lights flashing we followed them
and as we did we arrived at the area of
a nerd-off where we there understood
that a police operation was underway and
that the chief suspect 29 year old
Shirley schuk at France's most wanted
man had been shot dead by authorities
essentially what happened is they'd been
an earlier operation there in the day
police had left then later that evening
there was a tip-off and police then came
across a man resembling shelleyf
checkout they tried to speak to him when
they did he opened fire on them they
returned in kind neutralizing the
suspect and then when we were in the
area of nod off we gradually saw people
start to come back out onto the streets
they were relieved after a tense few
days a 50 hour manhunt an international
manhunt of earth for this man people are
out on the streets people had opened up
their their sash windows are sharing a
glass of wine with officers some people
were going around handing out Mackinaw
little cakes typical to the region here
in France so it's been very much a tense
few days and that area where he was shot
and killed Hana I mean it's not only the
area where they eventually you know
neutralized him as you as you say it's
also where he vanished shortly after the
shooting why did it take police so long
to find him that's the big question
today Sarah that is the question that
security forces will have to look into
remember of course that France has been
on its highest level of alert over 700
offices here in France were mobilized
officers also mobilized across the
border in Germany border checks were in
place and Shelley Shawkat was found
exactly where he disappeared which means
that although as you can see here in
Strasbourg with the Christmas lights are
back on the market here is open of a
regular market and life is getting back
to normal and the investigation for most
people here in Scottsburg is concluded
for authorities they have to work out
who knew what how was it possible that
this man could have evaded authorities
on several occasions slip under the
radar and eventually be found in the
very place he disappeared some fifty
hours ago in Strasbourg no less tell us
a little bit more about that Helen that
area Hana because I know you've been
reporting extensively from there in the
past 24 hours it's where he was from it
was not far from where police found him
what more do we know that's right Sarah
we thought it was really important to go
to at the estate where jellyfish a cat
lived to understand a little bit more
about the man who had 27 criminal
convictions starting from the age of 13
we went to a housing estate kernig is
often just a little bit west of nod off
of course when we spoke to people there
who knew him they said they were
absolutely dismayed at the events of
Tuesday evening here but that said they
did talk about an area where
unemployment is high where job
opportunities are few education
opportunities are few we spoke to a
community worker who said that can
really lead to frustration here and we
also spoke to someone who said that you
know France's secular policy makes them
feel sometimes as Muslims that they are
being stigmatized but they are the ones
that are being made an example of and
all of these factors of course can
create friction in French society and
that's something that France continues
to struggle with 2015 of course was the
moment where increasing terrorism
attacks came here on French soil and all
of these things are something that the
government will have to consider the
investigation just began
Helena Humphrey in Strasbourg thank you
so much